aucun militaire russe n'est présent on
allait affirmé le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov la présidence
russe réagissait ainsi à la déclaration
du chef de la diplomatie française jean
yves le drian qui a qualifié d'
incompatible une éventuelle implication
de la société militaire privée wagner
dans le pays avec le maintien des forces
françaises je vous propose d'écouter
nous n'avons aucune information à ce
sujet
et pour revenir à votre question
il n'y a là bas aucun représentant des
forces armées russes
et aucune négociation officielle est en
cours lui partant de ce fait
ce n'est pas la première fois que le
chef de la diplomatie française
s'inquiète du rôle accru de la russie en
afrique jean yves le drian avait dénoncé
je cite une présence active de la russie
récente significative antilles
françaises dans la république
centrafricaine jean yves le drian avait
ensuite confirmé que ce n'était pas
vraiment l'armée russe qui étaient
positionnées en centrafrique mais la
force wagner la russie a toujours
affirmé que son aide en centrafrique se
faisait conformément au droit et aux
objectifs de la communauté
internationale écoutez nous pouvons
répéter qu'en réponse à la demande des
dirigeants centrafricain et au su du
comité des sanctions du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu 21 27 pour la
république centrafricaine
175 instructeur russe chargé de former
le personnel militaire centrafricain ont
été envoyés dans ce pays en 2018 par la
suite le nombre des instructeurs est
passé à 235 étant donné le fait que la
situation s'est fortement aggravée à la
veille des élections législatives de
décembre 2020 la russie à la demande des
autorités centrafricaines à envoyer 300
instructeurs de plus dans ce pays pour
former le personnel de l'armée nationale
chargée d'assurer la sécurité avant et
pendant le scrutin récemment un autre
groupe de six ans instructeur est
arrivée à bangui 200 pour l'armée 200
pour la police et 200 pour la
gendarmerie nationale une notification
en ce sens a également été envoyée au
comité des sanctions du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu 21 27 d'après moscou
aucun instructeur russe n'est
directement impliqués dans les
hostilités contre les groupes armés
illégaux dans la république
centrafricaine